the national transportation safety board  still investigating that plane crash  that killed two people in the south  valley  of course that happened yesterday  morning we told you about it here at 4  not too far from valley view in pebble  now not long after the pilot radioed the  tower indicating they were having  trouble  there were two people on board the  cessna the plane was headed from  north las vegas to an airport in san  diego while no official identification  has been confirmed  friends of the pilot are identifying him  as robert golo  he is the owner of air charter express  the name of the other person on the  plane has not yet been